what's going on reject nation we got
ourselves
a little short clip from the snyder cut
steppenwolf versus the amazons it's in
black and white if i'm not mistaken yeah
so before watching this
um i complained to the management team
at this building because
there's no hot water because the hot
water is either not working or the water
is completely off
once i move out of this place i'm going
to give you guys the exact address of
this building so none of you guys ever
have to live here
and the other thing is that we watch the
amazon's clip from the joss whedon cut
so we can do a decent comparison since
this is a very short snippet from i'm
assuming the same moment there's only
one moment in that
in that uh joss whedon cup where you
know what i'm trying to say all right
let's do it
[Music]
damn oh
shall we
valentine's day what a weird day to
release it's true
justice league is for lovers
i'm pretty excited for this man full on
trailer i mean we got an actual trailer
for it before it'll be an hour long
trailer though i feel like there's
actually going to be like dialogue
hopefully won't just have some copyright
song that you hear everyone who's
covering the trailer talking about and
bitching about
maybe it'll have some actual new footage
from scenes we've never
seen before in other contexts but in
terms of this clip i mean yeah when you
compare it
to what it was before there's just so
much more going on here the ruthlessness
of this
guy and the force that he has the fact
that he's got like
all these arrows and they on his back
and they're just trying to take him down
but no matter what
they hurl at him he's just like no i'm
coming for you and the way he's just
throwing everyone around this is
brutal this is badass i'm not
i'm not over selling it here that is the
stepping steppenwolf that we wanted to
see
someone who's just like he's a force of
nature no matter what
goes on you can't seem to take this guy
down he does come across just so much
more feral and even the resistance from
the amazons
feels a lot more of a struggle a lot
more intense
yeah and i mean you know the black and
white imagery also i think adds to that
it's like it's
it's like watching someone almost be
tortured it's like they got it tied up
by the
feet and the arms there's just nothing
stopping him while he's swinging around
the lightning's going on
god damn that's intense the axe even
looks more menacing in this shot
this feels like scary yeah the design
too i mean he does look a lot more
pointy a lot more
sharp a lot more just menacing and nasty
like you look at the
joss whedon cut scene and it does feel
like something out of a more bouncy
superhero yeah
you're like the peril is contained
whereas this feels like a
battle this feels like a struggle yeah
big struggle yeah
well snyder cut leave your thoughts down
below if you think steppenwolf will
be improved subscribe click the
notification button if i want a reaction
for that trailer is up
catch you guys soon